- I got this record
that I wanted to play you.
- I can't wait, man.
I've been so excited.
I've been trying to
get this whole day to go,
I couldn't wait for this
day to get done to get here.
(Ferg laughs)
("Unstoppable"
by This Is Wolff)
- Pat McAfee, very
nice to meet you, man.
- [Gary] It's a pleasure, Pat.
How are you?
Thank you brother.
- Nice to meet you, God damn.
- I'm excited
to be here, my man.
- Yeah, let's go
fucking crush this.
- [Gary] Let's do it.
I'm excited.
- Thank you for stopping by.
- [Gary] Of course.
- This is a big favor for us.
- [Gary] Listen,
same for me, man.
You guys are doing good shit.
Sorry, I'm like
trying to get my,
trying to get
health insurance here.
Trying to
activate my shit. (laughs)
- [Pat] I'm willing
to test the limits.
You want to get
in there and do this?
- [Gary] Yeah.
Let's do it.
- Let's do it.
You're the man.
- [Jason] Gary,
we're gonna put you right
back there if that's cool.
- Yeah, that's
super cool. How are you?
- [Jason] I'm good, I'm Jason.
- Jason, it's a real pleasure.
- [Jason] Hey man,
really enjoy your stuff.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- [Woman] How are you?
- [Gary] How are you?
You don't wear
shoes? What the fuck?
- [Woman] What do you
mean I don't wear shoes?
- Oh shit, I didn't
see them for a second.
I'm like you're bare footing it.
How are you?
- [Woman] Good, how you doin'?
- [Gary] Really good.
- [Pat] I watched, Shane Lechler
doesn't know this,--
- Raiders?
- [Pat] He was with the Raiders
and then he went to the Texans.
- Yep.
- [Pat] We had
to play him twice.
But my entire rookie year and
second year I just watched film
of him, literally every
single day trying to learn.
Shane Lechler and I bump the
exact same because I tried to
mimic everything he did
and that was my rookie year.
- You need him on this podcast.
That's very important, it can
be a huge theme of what you can
learn from people's actions.
You can change lives by
having Shane on the show.
- [Pat] Other people's lives?
- Yes.
(group laughter)
All humans lives based on the
way that you
mapped against Shane.
So this is a good segue, the
reason I do a daily vlog on
YouTube is don't
listen to what I'm saying,
watch what I'm doing. Right?
If I'm going all-in on Instagram
stories right now and putting up
20 pieces of content a day
that means I think it's smart.
Right?
If I'm going on the
best podcasts in the world,
not this one.
(group laughter)
You know?
- [Pat] Others.
- Yeah, others.
That means that
I think it's smart.
You knew that he was a big time
player and had a huge success
and you watched it.
I'm stunned by how many people
would rather read a book then
watch the behavior of
the people that are winning.
("Savages" by Anna Mae)
(Gary laughs)
I love you guys.
Thanks so much. Take care.
Thanks guys.
- [Pat] Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Congrats, bro.
I'm super pumped
for this this crew.
- [Pat] Thank you.
- [Gary] Cool, see ya guys.
Take care. See ya, man.
Yo, yo, yo Instagram.
Good to see ya,
good to see ya.
The biggest question so many
people struggle with is how to
actually start and do and
make these things
happen for themselves.
So I'm gonna
start dropping 11 A.M.
Monday, 11 A.M. Monday.
Beautiful day in the city.
Huh, DRock?
- [DRock] Beautiful.
- [Gary] Hope you
guys have a beautiful day.
Do something crazy.
Go out and say hello to somebody
you haven't said hello to.
Go to somebody in your
office right now or in your
neighborhood or the coffee store
and say what's up to somebody
you've never talked to before.
And what? Once in a
blue moon you sell
something really
expensive that's fun?
- [Michael] Yeah.
- I think I need a
store, too. I'm not kidding.
I love retail.
- [Michael] Retail is the
fucking front line and anybody
can walk in the door.
And they might be a lunatic
that just goto out of Bellview.
They might be a billionaire
who's visiting from Tokyo.
You have no fucking idea and
that trains an interesting
muscle in your intuition, in
your way you engage with people.
- It's changed, yeah.
It's how I got trained.
- [Michael] Right.
And really, it's a special thing
that is very under appreciated.
- [Gary] The biggest
single sale that I ever made in
Wine Library, in the store, not
on the internet was a guy that
came in in combat boots and
dragged mud into the store,
not joking.
- [Michael] Right.
- $40,000, one drop.
- [Michael] One moment.
- And, Charles Pearson
if you're watching.
Charles Pearson, stock guy
came up to me and said,
"Do you want me to
keep an eye on the guy?"
Literally, when he
walked in he thought the
guy might steal something.
- [Michael] Right.
(laughs)
- Life. You're
gonna laugh at this.
I may want to give
you a quote for the book.
- [Michael] Oh, that'd be cool.
- I never do it.
People ask me all the time,
but I just really
like this subject matter.
Good first meeting.
I like Michael a lot.
Smart guy. Good vibes.
Makes sense that he's so
deep into empathy, right?
That's why I always
intuitively liked him.
("Savages" by Anna Mae)
I know. Like I know what we do.
We're breaking the
model and we're selling shit.
Like it works.
Like it fucking works.
Client meeting.
Hello Iris.
- Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- Good, how are you?
I just wanted to thank you
'cause a lot of the things that
you talk about has really
inspired me and my mindset and
perspective so first off like
I just want to say thank you.
- [Gary] Thanks Iris.
That's the gear that
I think you probably,
again, you may have.
- I'm starting to learn it.
- It's real.
- Yeah.
- It's real and when you know
you have a new video tomorrow,
you get a little
less romantic, right?
- [DRock] That's
the most important part.
- But the marriage
of the both--
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Correct.
- is the way you want to go.
- The reason we can win is right
now we're just putting out.
Like we're not winning.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- To the level we deserve.
- Correct.
- DRock.
- [Andy] DRock.
- [Gary] Alright, break.
- [Man] Hey. How are you?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
Nope.
We're a funny company. (laughs)
- How long you need?
- [Gary] I think so.
How you doin'?
- [Tyler] Great.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Tom] How we doin'?
Good to see you.
Nice digs.
- Thank you.
Not to shabby, huh?
- Not too shabby at all, man.
It's absolutely incredible.
- [Gary] Yeah, it's pretty rad.
- I love what you've built.
The people that greet you to the
people that shoot with you to
the people that
run the accounts,
just incredible, incredible and
that's how I know what you're
doing with
culture is not bullshit.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- As somebody that has
scaled an organization,
I know how fucking hard that is.
So you've done an
amazing job and this,
you already know,
but they like each other.
- [Gary] It's huge.
- And that was the
time when I was like whoa,
you've really got
something special.
- [Gary] Thank you, my man.
Thank you. I appreciate it.
Thank you.
(laughs) Having you guys in the
corner of my eye while that was
going on might've
been the best part.
I'll see you guys later?
People think you look like
Sheamus the wrestler, right?
I think you do.
Remember Sheamus,
the big Irish wrestler?
The last 10 years in WWE.
I think you look like him.
Yo!
I'm trying, my man.
Thank you, my man.
This had a phone
number that I called...
They're doing a nice job here.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Gary] Like it's
coming along way better
than I thought it would.
Pssst.
- Hey.
- [Gary] How's your day?
Hanging in.
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)
- [Drew] Big fan.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Drew] Drew Cameron.
- [Gary] Drew. Gary Vaynerchuk.
- That's my son, Tyler.
- [Gary] Tyler, Gary.
- What are you working on?
- I do a daily vlog
so I'm always filming.
And then just running to a
business meeting with a client.
- Gotcha, don't
want to interrupt.
Can I get a picture with you?
- [Gary] Of course, of course.
Awesome.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Thanks
for saying hello.
- Appreciate all your work.
- Nice meeting you, man.
Real pleasure.
Yeah, have a good time.
Take care.
- [Man 2] Yo, Gary.
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Man 2] What up, man?
- What up, man?
- Yo, I'm Aaron's
partner from Propeller.
- Oh, no kidding.
- We met briefly.
- Yes.
- I don't know if you remember.
- Very quickly, I remember.
- Yeah.
- In the beginning when I first
got there I remember you kind of
like in that gated area.
- Yeah.
- I remember.
- It was like the VIP section.
- You have a good memory, man.
Do you mind if we take a selfie?
- Yeah. Yeah, sure.
- Excuse me.
- [Gary] My man.
- [Man 2] Thank you, my man.
- [Gary] Take care.
Good luck on the new one.
Yeah, tell him I said what's up?
Yo, what's up, my man?
- [Kevin] How you doin'?
- [Gary] I'm doing
really well, how are you?
- Pretty well, pretty well.
- [Gary] Cool, man.
- Nice meeting you.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
What's your name?
- Kevin.
- [Gary] Kevin.
Thanks for saying hello.
- Yeah, your videos
man, they're motivational.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, so I'm going
into a meeting with
a client now form Diageo.
He's on the phone and we're
gonna have a nice little drinks
here 'cause summer
time is in the air,
DRock, which I love.
And then I'm going to meet
with a business connection for
another dinner and drinks and
then I'm gonna meet up with you
DRock and we're gonna go into
the studio and do our thing.
It's good times to be alive.
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)
Just got back
from a really great
dinner that I
told you about earlier.
Really interesting power player.
Good dude.
Now at the studio in midtown.
You've seen me here before.
This is the
second trip here, DRock.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- This time gonna jam with my
boy A$AP Ferg
and gonna make
some magic happen.
How you doin', DRock?
- [DRock] Doing great.
- Awesome.
(elevator beeping)
Is there a bathroom?
Hey Boyd. Hey Ty.
Cool.
(indistinct chatter)
- [Man 3] My man, GaryVee.
- What's up, man?
- [Gary] What up, my man?
- What's goin' on, bro?
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good, brother.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
- [Man 3] Everything good?
- [Gary] Real good.
What's up, handsome?
- What's going on?
- [Gary] My man.
How you doin'?
- Hey Gary, you know G Easy?
- [Gary] What's up my man?
- How's it going man?
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
How are you?
Much love.
- Something great.
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)
- How are you?
Thank you, darlin'.
Awesome.
Gary.
- [Tanner] Tanner.
- [Gary] I'm trying, man.
I saw your muscles the
last time you were through.
I'm good.
- So I got this record
that I wanted to play you.
- I can't wait, man.
I've been so excited.
I've been trying to
get this whole day to go,
I couldn't wait for this
day to get done to get here.
(Ferg laughs)
- I just came
back from Africa, too.
- Is that right?
- Yeah.
- When are we going to Ghana?
- [Tyler] June 2nd.
- June 2nd?
I'm going June 2nd to Ghana.
- You going to Ghana.
- Uh-huh.
- What are you
gonna do out there?
- I'm on the board of something
called Pencils of Promise.
- [Man 3] Digital mix, it's
a digital album pretty much.
- For sale, or just put out?
- For sale.
- For sale?
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- Through what? iTunes?
- [Man 3] iTunes,
Spotify, everywhere. All DSPs.
- Let us know how we can help.
- [Man 3] Absolutely.
- Obviously, I mean.
I can really help especially if
I'm gonna be part of one song.
I can really help.
So this is like, what,
one of the real studios, right?
'Cause we've come
through here a couple times now.
- This is the one
Tupac got shot at.
- Get the fuck--
- [Man 3] The first time.
- The first time.
- Yeah, the first time, yeah.
- Is that right?
I remember.
- They blamed it on Biggie.
- I remember.
That was the real
moment where shit got weird.
- Yeah. (laughs) Yeah.
- [Gary] Man,
I wish I could rap.
- [Ferg] You could rap.
You'll probably have a
lot to talk about, too.
- I wish I could.
Like I can, what's that?
- You said I
really wish I could.
- Like I know when I speak and
it comes off comedy and improv.
I know what I can,
it's self-awareness.
You know, is that your ring?
- [Woman 2] Yes.
- Let me see that.
That is real fly.
- [Woman 2] Thank you.
- I love that.
If I could rap I'd
be fucking rapping.
I would've
rapped it all up by now.
(group laughter)
I would just kill people.
I woulda sold all my businesses.
I would be on my way.
But I hate Wall Street.
Those fuckers cheat.
- [Ferg] Yeah, he hates 'em.
- That's a real bummer.
I'm thrilled to put that.
They do.
- [Man 3] You're on your way, G.
You're on your way.
- I really want it.
I want it, I want it, I want it.
I wish I, you know, you
guys can't trick me into it.
I know I'm not but.
- While he's talking, 'cause
he's gonna go over there
and say like some--
- [Gary] Motivational shit?
- motivational like--
- [Gary] I'm already angry.
I haven't even
got in the booth yet.
- [Ferg] Angry Gary.
- I need to listen
to it a couple times.
Let's start from the
top again one more time.
- Click or whatever, then
it's gonna activate everything.
- [Gary] One song gets used on
a video game that becomes the
biggest video game.
Like one show uses like
a hook in the background.
One celebrity
lips on Musical.ly.
You just don't know
where it's gonna come from.
- That's why you
just got to keep working.
- [Gary] My concern is that no
one can oversaturate because the
supply and demand of the noise.
- [Ferg] Right.
- That's what I've
been thinking a lot about.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- We had Kyle in the other day.
- [Boyd] Yeah.
- No matter how big
outside of like three artist,
I don't know.
Look how much
shit Drake puts out.
- [Man 3] That's true.
- Drake put out fuckin'...
- But he doesn't put
out a lot of content.
- [Gary] No, but he
puts out a lot of music.
It's just there's so much noise.
You know what's
been fucking with me?
This is something I haven't
talked a lot about but this is
the same thesis.
So my whole life,
everything I'm about,
even right now, I still just
care so much about my legacy.
So much I think about is
what's gonna happen when I die.
- [Ferg] I used to get
depressed about that shit.
- So, listen to this.
You'll like this.
- [Ferg] I'm like, yo, how am I
gonna be as big as Genghis Khan?
Or like will I be
remembered like Michael Jackson?
- [Gary] Yeah, that's
how I thought about it.
- Ghandi and some shit.
- [Gary] That's right.
I was like if I die,
I really want the world to stop
for a couple days.
Back even 10, 15 years ago.
CNN, fucking show shit.
I want my fucking kids crying.
I want the world to stop.
Then, this is real, Prince and
David Bowie died, right?
I guess last
year, in '16, right?
- [Ferg] Right.
- And I got fucked up.
I'm like fuck people only
give a fuck for like nine hours.
- [Ferg] That's fucked up, bro.
- [Gary] And this is
how I think about music.
We, us, content producers.
Business videos, musicians, we
have our own pride and our own
egos and our own lives and we
think over-saturation and
I think yeah, but, like
there's just so much now.
It's not like when fucking I
grew up when like you went to
Sam Goody when
fucking the new, you know,
NAS album came out.
And like seven albums, shit's
just coming at these kids 24/7
and it becomes a
supply and demand game.
And my big thing is, so wait,
you're putting out a
mixtape and an album?
- [Ferg] Yeah.
- How many songs?
- [Man 3] 12 and about 14.
- [Gary] Good, 26.
- [Man 3] Yep.
- [Gary] You know how
many songs you actually have?
- I got a lot of songs.
- [Gary] I know you do, my man.
I think you can
make 27 songs tonight.
- Right.
- [Gary] Whatever,
you know what I mean.
- [Man 3] Yeah, absolutely.
- [Gary] And I'm
always wondering like,
I said to Kyle when I was with
him the other day I was like
Prince's seven biggest songs
never saw the day of life.
You know that fucked with me
the other day when they found,
six months ago they
found all the
music in his, yeah.
And I'm always like what if his
fuckin' seven best songs never.
- [Ferg] Yeah.
- [Man 3] Right.
- [Ferg] 'Cause he
probably second guessed.
- I promise you the 11 best
hooks you ever came up with in
your head, you
just thought about it.
You know you lose 'em.
I know I do.
Some of the best shit
I ever thought of I know I lost.
That's why I vlog.
- [Ferg] Yeah.
- That's why I vlog now.
You should vlog, man.
You're real interesting.
You would kill it.
- [Ferg] Yeah.
- 'Cause you're multidimensional
and people don't know.
People kinda
know but not as much.
- [Ferg] Right.
- [Gary] Come in here,
it'll help me.
- [Man 3] What's
the dude that was
supposed to manage Mike Tyson.
- Oh, what's his name?
God, I love that dude.
- [Ferg] The
one that passed away.
- Oh, Cus D'Amato.
- [Ferg] Yeah, Cus D'Amato.
You're like my Cus D'Amato.
- I love it.
- [Ferg] You're basically
just talking about what
we were just talking about.
- I get it.
- It's not sleep,
I mean it's sleep,
but just keep going.
- What you do when you're awake.
- [Ferg] Yeah.
Keep going.
Not too much explaining.
- I know how to drop one liners.
That's all I know. You know?
That's how I communicate.
- Oh yeah, you can
give me some headphones.
(laughs)
- I can't wait for this.
I'm so excited, I can't breathe.
I'm more excited about
this than I am my next book.
- You know, oh yeah,
I got to read that book.
- I'll get it to you early.
- You know I get a lot of people
coming to me that heard our
conversation when
I was at your office.
- Is that right?
- And they love it.
- People, same for me.
- They go crazy.
- That's what I was
telling you about.
My man, you're
really sitting on something.
And you're a young dude, too.
- Ah, man.
- You're a baby.
- 'Preciate that.
- You accomplished so much
already that it fucks with you.
You don't have perspective.
I mean it.
- Mmmm.
- You've accomplished
so much already--
- Right.
- that you don't realize
how much there's more to go.
- Wow.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Seriously, you
know when you're hungry,
when you're young.
Like all these
things have happened and
it's hard to understand.
For me too.
Like it's hard to understand
how much more there is to go.
- Right. Right.
- Yeah, man.
I'm real excited.
- This is monumental.
- We're gonna, I'm gonna make
this the fucking
entrepreneurial anthem.
- Woo! (laughs)
- That's what I'm gonna do.
I don't give a fuck
what everybody thinks.
(Ferg and Gary laugh)
Want to do it again?
- That was good shit.
Nah, you want to
come out and listen to it?
- Yeah, okay.
Let me see, let me hear it.
(group laughter)
- [Ferg] Yo, you're
too good at that shit.
- [Gary] Oh man.
I got excited.
I get so competitive.
That's my problem.
It's about to happen.
DRock, this is crazy.
- [DRock] Nuts.
- You excited?
What do you think, Boyd?
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)
I need you, Ferg.
I need to look at you.
You make me excited. (laughs)
Right?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- It's so true.
- Yo Trap Lord,
tell 'em. Tell 'em!
- [Ferg] What it is, man.
- Tell 'em.
- Coming soon, ya hear.
- Dropping when?
- [Ferg] I ain't gonna drop no
dates 'cause I don't want to
disappoint but we
got GaryVee on there.
- Don't tell 'em, Ferg.
("Landslide" by Jimi Tents)